you know what i realized that you know
what i was sad and i had a deep
realization today
that people a lot of people just said
it's garbage in the mail
well that too i haven't looked yet but
oh boy did i
um i grew up always liking billy joel
because it's like legally required
if you grew up on long island and so
i was putting new music in my car's hard
drive
and i was like yeah put some billy joel
on there and listen to billy joe a long
time
billy joel sucks yeah i know billy joel
stinks
i i was like listening and i'm like this
is [ __ ] this
i'm like i always felt like wow people
always say like wow billy joel's really
good
turns out it was just the 70s
hey listen [ __ ] we only sing 80s
dog i'll take your skate cooker wife and
get the [ __ ] out of here
i saw billy joel live at bonnaroo
he was like the headlining act about
four or five years ago
is this when he was starting to look
like donald pleasance from when they
took the
mask off darth vader yeah he looked like
he that's exactly what he looked like
especially when he has a harmonica on
so i watched him do that and normally
like you know the headlining act of any
music festival is big it's a big you
know it's
they're they're going to close it out
they're going to rock all the way till
the end
he ended like 45 minutes early
he he's tired he was just
no interaction he was phoning it in yeah
he did piano man half-assed and then you
know it was like i've never really been
a big
fan of billy joel to begin with i
understand why you liked him you had to
and
it's like you have to like bon jovi from
new jersey he still has a couple of
bangers
but overall like all this uptown girl
no uh he's got a couple good song uptown
girls good
uh i go to extremes is good
um there's a couple songs that are good
right but like
i'm listening to him and i'm just like
like most of the songs he's known for
like piano man
captain jack and i'm like driving and
i'm like
billy joel [ __ ] sucks like i was
trying i was like wow he [ __ ] sucks
like
i don't know if i've changed i don't if
i could judge
you could show i don't know who changed
in this in this relationship
but uh he's good [ __ ] stinks he's
good at drinking bad at driving
he's yeah it's just unless he's driving
into someone's home i was just like
i'm like these aren't good
these songs aren't good like some of the
songs are okay
but it's like ah i was just driving it
bummed me out today i was like god have
i reached a point now where [ __ ]
billy joel sucks
i can't even enjoy billy joel anymore i
still like a lot of old rock i just i
never liked billy joel
to me i don't like any i don't like any
band outside of
maybe elton john where the piano is the
main instrument
you know yeah she's not i just ah and
even then elton john has a couple i
wouldn't say i'm a super fan of his you
know
but yeah but even like the the
the songs like uh like i used to like
allentown right
but i'm like driving and i'm like this
whole song is so stupid like it's all
there
is then they're taking off the coat from
the ground like this is so stupid
and then i'm like driving and then uh oh
god
night saigon comes on what a piece of
[ __ ] that song is
whenever billy joel tried to be like
political you know what i mean like
you're like oh let's talk about the war
in vietnam man
it's just so bad i was just i was
embarrassed
for myself listening to [ __ ] billy
joel
and then uh uh what was the other one
that was bothering me
um [ __ ] there was just there's just so
many bad songs
he's not good i i take it back billy
joel's not good
no he's not and you know the one i was
talking about a couple days ago on day
wave was springsteen
what an overrated piece of [ __ ]
springsteen is springsteen's
not just bad [ __ ]
no no springsteen's pretty good
compared to billy joel he's pretty good
no spring scene is worse
gloria no it's dancing in the dark yeah
i'm sure it is
uh look let me tell you why [ __ ]
springsteen's worse okay
first off he suffers from the same thing
that billy joel does where
he's like factory town i'm a factory man
i'm working in a factory with factory
plans
like [ __ ] you but you know i looked up
springsteen
that motherfucker's never had a real job
he's been in a band his whole life
okay so i hate that oh and i don't like
that oh it is
singing no [ __ ] thank you
springsteen's a [ __ ] hack i don't
even like bon jovi but if i had to pick
a new jersey band
i'm gonna i'm gonna pick bon jovi over
springsteen springsteen
[ __ ] sucks he's pretty sprigstine is
factory rock
and it's [ __ ] terrible i'm certainly
not going to dig a foxhole and fight
royce over this like to the point where
like springsteen rule like
i'm not going to be one of those to put
an american bandana on
start fighting yeah fighting like uh
hiding like rainbow in the jungle
not that serious about it uh but he is
good i will say springsteen's all right
compared to [ __ ] billy joel dude
[ __ ] we didn't start the fire came
on and it's just naming things did you
know born in the usa is actually an
anti-american song wow you're so edgy
bruce
flipping through a newspaper i am
reading words on here i am just saying
things
in the newspaper this is what's on page
six this is on
page eight and we're on page 11. now
we're on patrick
that's probably the song that i hate the
most by billy joel
that i hate the [ __ ] most by him so
look i'm not arguing with you because i
also don't like billy joel
but i like billy joel springsteen you
know like glory days
no glory days is a good glory days is a
boomer [ __ ] song
nah glory days is dope is it what's your
favorite part about
what's glory day's about if you say his
glory days i'll
it's about uh people thinking about
their glory days
see that's you can't describe a song but
it is what the song's about
i know i mean you know springsteen
wasn't exactly a clever guy
he wasn't writing clever titles [ __ ]
bruce springsteen i say
he's bad i'll tell you what i'd rather
replace that billy joel [ __ ]
uh set of music in my car with [ __ ]
springsteen i could rock to some
springsteen
i'd rather replace [ __ ] both with the
10 10 wins
like i'd rather replace both with box
scores from baseball
i i just i springsteen song i had a
friend that was a big baseball player
back in high school he could throw that
speed ball by you
but you make you look like a fool boy
you don't need
10 10 wins you just need to listen if we
didn't start the fire you get all the
news
so bad it's such a bad section's on
china and we're going to iran
and we're going to show biden's falling
asleep you should make it updated first
okay cool how about glory days they'll
pass you
by glory days of a young girl's eyes
glory days oh wow [ __ ] deep writing
with [ __ ] hack springsteen all these
most of these bands sucked
we were just lying to ourselves how come
how come billy joel doesn't
didn't do an updated version of like
they've been telling
you know it's funny because they've been
asking him to do that for a while and he
just said he won't do it orange man
really bad
like all that kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
q says trust the plan oh we should do it
let's [ __ ] do it and you know what
will you agree with me on this one
bob dylan great songwriter terrible
singer
he wasn't that great of a songwriter
either no he wrote a lot of songs
yeah he wrote a lot along the watchtower
was him that's pretty good song
i liked it when i said he wasn't that
good royce goes he wrote a lot he didn't
say good song
he wrote a lot of songs fair enough it's
like going no he played a lot it's like
cal ripken
he showed up to a lot of games well
carter was really good too
he's good but it's like his biggest
accomplishment is he
had good attendance that's literally
what a nerd hey
you're a [ __ ] nerd i get that he was
good but he was good like what on the
orioles
okay look my point is bambi we're gonna
take your children
and we're gonna cut their penis off and
give them abortions whether they like it
or not
well look look my point is this bob
dylan has written
a lot of popular how i could say this
way so doesn't it right bob dylan has
written a lot of popular songs
hey mr tambourine man play a song for me
i said popular i said i just i just
fixed it i just fixed it right yeah
i just i don't like him so you trust me
i'm not gonna defend him so
bob dylan's written a lot of songs that
were commercially popular so he wrote
all along the watchtower uh the ballad
of easy writer
okay he did all along the watchtower
right but we could all admit he also did
the worst version of
all oh of course nobody gives a [ __ ]
about his version of it
so he you know he wrote you know
stranger who
wrote half of wagon wheel and then
someone else finished it
um but bob dylan's another one where
people just praised this [ __ ]
and uh
what did he do what did bob don't do
that was so [ __ ] impressive yeah my
dad liked bob dylan and my dad had [ __ ]
taste in everything so i'm going with
that approach
he just wasn't yeah hey mr tambourine
man play a song for me is one of the
worst
[ __ ] lyrics ever written it's it
tastes bad you're right
it's almost as bad as singing a song
you're the piano man
like it's just by the way any any
musician
songs about being a musician is the
[ __ ]
and i know tambourine man was about a
drug dealer but the point being
was it dude when when these [ __ ]
musicians can't even think of an analogy
outside of music so they're like i need
i need an analogy
for heroin and you're like what if we
what if the heroin was like
a guy who played a tambourine man and
you're like why don't you
[ __ ] leave the music studio once in a
while and
at least billy joel at least billy joel
would eat at a sidewalk cafe
and [ __ ] watch the construction
workers across the street
and go uh and um get my jackhammer and
just
hitting the cement with my hammer i
don't know why he's eating a quiche
like just some expensive breakfast hard
hat hard
hat there are some i can rhyme so many
things with hard hat
there's there's somebody in the chat
that's like rediverse is morons oh
is this guy doing the listen to the
words yeah
oh no no don't do that don't do the
listen to the word thing
bro did you put the song on or did you
really listen to it man
i hate people that do the listen to the
lyrics thing
oh [ __ ] you know what uh let's how about
i do that
your brother used to do that yeah i
wanted to punch you right in the face oh
man
you know have you like heard smash mouth
or have you
really listened to it man it's like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
so hey mr tambourine man play a song for
me
i'm not sleepy and there's no place i'm
going to hey mr tamrie man play a song
for me
in the jingle jangle morning i'll come
following you
okay now if you're going to write a song
about drugs like that's a real
roundabout way to do it right
so could i do an updated version can we
do like a modern song about drugs
okay if you want to write a modern song
about drugs it would be more like hannah
montana hannah montana animals i got
molly i got white
molly i got white i've been chirping
chirping chirping all damn night
that's better than see now that's we
know exactly what drugs are for sale
you know what i mean though i know that
evening's empire's returning to sand
vanish from my hand this is like some
theater kid writing a poem to his
girlfriend
left me blindly here to stand but still
not sleeping my weirdness amazes me
i'm branded on my feet i have no one to
meet and the ancient empty streets too
dead for dreaming yeah i have a
boyfriend
all right sorry susan it's just walk
away show your [ __ ]
down walk away with your head down
someday i'm gonna get some [ __ ]
[ __ ] you bob dylan [ __ ] you bob dylan
[ __ ] you for spring stay [ __ ] you billy
joel
we're gonna destroy all of your idols
they all suck all right
enough you're literally the only guy in
history to ever pick up an electric
guitar and be worse
yeah so you know what i mean [ __ ] [ __ ]
bob dylan
[ __ ] billy joel he ruined my whole ride
over here yeah [ __ ] billy joel
there's still like three solid billy
joel songs and i'll say the same thing
springsteen still has a few where
i'll be like that's my jam but i've
never in my life asked
somebody to play springsteen like i've
never been like yo throw some bruce
springsteen on
but like if glory days is playing i'm
like alright this song's alright
um i still stand by dancing in the dark
is pretty pretty dope and then there was
one other one that i liked
there was one other stupid springsteen
song that i liked
and at billy joel uh i still stand by i
go to extremes that's still a good song
but then it's like
you know and i'm on the down easter
alexa he's like singing about
by the way he's trying to by the way
this was the down eastern alexa
was a boat billy joel bought and named
after his daughter
and it was like a like a [ __ ] 750 000
boat that he bought when he was like
living in the hamptons but then he tried
to write a song about his boat
and then he realized when he's writing a
song about his boat that writing about
his 750 000
yacht in the hamptons is probably not
gonna so then he had to change the song
to be like about a commercial fisherman
but like all his references are like
oyster bay and like all these places in
long island that like they don't have
commercial fishing anymore like
there's no commercial fishing in the
hamptons and he's like
i'm trying to survive on fish
sticks or whatever he's like trying to
sing about feeding his kids but you're
like
[ __ ] it was just in page six you
bought like a million dollar yacht what
are you talking
it has gold fixtures on it [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so you're a big fan of born to run
interesting born to run yes
that's a good one that's a good song no
it is no and elvis sucked too